hi there today we're looking at evolving
normalization activation layers by Han
Jia Liu Andrew Brock Karin's Simonian
and really these are people from Google
brain and google deepmind the topic of
this paper is as you can see it it's
about normalization activation layers
and we want to evolve them
I think the peripheral title says a lot
but let's go down here and see what this
is about
so we'll look at image neural networks
and current architectures are kind of
focused around the same principles what
they'll have is so ever since resonate
you these neural networks will be
composed of these kind of blocks that
come one after another so there will be
a block up here and then the signal will
propagate and there will be another
block down here now these blocks usually
consist of what's called a skip
connection out here this is the
fundamental ingredient of resonance that
made resonance so so effective seems to
be the introduction of this skip
connection you see all of these have the
skip connection here so these are
variants on resonance and then we see
that these are always mixed between
convolutional layers and then other
things that here are called Evo norm now
in a classic resonate you would have
something like a convolutional layer
then you would have a batch
normalization and then you would have a
non-linearity for example a rail ooh and
then you would go on to the next
convolutional layer so you see that the
paper mainly cares about these two
layers here at the batch norm and the
rail ooh and it combines them into what
it's called a cause an evil norm so the
evil norm layers here are supposed to
replace the normalization and the
activation layers combine them and
make them better and how does it do that
through evolutionary search alright so
these three models here are the ResNet
mobile net and efficient net or
architectures they're all image
classifier or architectures all right so
let's see how it does that what it does
is it evolves these layers from single
primitives now if you see the batch
normalization paper then you know that
these the batch normalization is it's
just kind of a formula you can write
down all right and these other
normalization methods so people have
developed other ones than batch norm for
example this is group norm with a ray Lu
activation function and you can write
these two layers down as this
mathematical expression so it features
things like this is the input signal I
think this is the mean across some
groups this is a bias term that you can
train this is the standard deviation
across the same groups and so on so and
this here is the Darrell ooh term so you
can you can kind of write this down
as a combination of these primitives and
the so you can write it in a graph now
this graph here is actually a an
activation function that this paper has
found its called Evo norm s0 and the
mathematical equation is the thing down
here it's not that different you can see
from previous activations it also has
the input signal it has the this
variance or standard deviation across
groups it has a non-linearity here and
the graph here is is simply a graph of
mathematical operations made out of
primitives right so this paper takes all
of the primitives that they can think of
and puts them in this table they say
okay
our search space for these layers so we
want to evolve these layers our search
space is a combination of any of these
primitives so you can see here you have
something like addition multiplication
naked like negation so you can you can
subtract things you can take the log of
things you can take the square root and
so on so your even max which is the Ray
Lu activation function but if you if you
put zero as one of them you have the
sigmoid which is another non-linearity
then you can also do something like I
want to compute the batch mean or I want
to compute a group standard deviation
pretty much anything that current
activation functions that have been
handcrafted use are available as
primitives across this search so how
does this method search this is the
process of how the method searches it
does this in an evolutionary way and
evolutionary protocols it means that you
don't develop one layer like you would
do with you if you were to do something
like gradient descent you develop a
whole population of layers so these can
be maybe a couple of hundred or a couple
of thousand different or layer
architectures that you develop at the
same time right what you do each time
you put them into a tournament which
basically means you want a sample a
couple of them I don't think they do all
at the same time they sample a couple of
them right and then they terrain on what
they call a proxy task their proxy task
is C 410 so C 410 is a fairly small
image classification task and they train
on C 4/10 because it's it's pretty fast
right you can train something on C 410
in like a couple of minutes or an hour
or so and get a pretty good feeling for
how good the final accuracy will be you
can get that pretty fast so this is a
fast classification that's because they
need to do this a lot right the
population is large and they need to
is overtime right in any case they take
a sample they trained on C for 10 and
then the winner the waning layer is
picked from the sample and only the
winning layer is allowed to mutate right
so the winning layer is mutated then an
mutation means you kind of change it a
bit now you don't change it in an
in-form the way you just change it at
random and of course the and then you
put put the new tailored layers back
into the population of course the hope
is that by repeating this process right
you repeat and repeat and repeat that
the simply by picking the winning layers
over and over and over again is a
selective pressure such that through the
random mutations but the tournament
style evaluation and picking of the
winner that over time the best
performing models in your population
write the best scoring model here will
get better and better and better right
so the assumption is that this isn't
like a pure combinatorial optimization
or like a pure random function is that
if I take something that works well
there are ways that I can perturb it
that will make it work even better right
even if most of the perturbations are
worse that there are some and the
tournament-style will always will always
find these ones for me that perform
better and then I can modify these again
at random and then among these I can
again find the ones that perform even
better so that is the the method and so
the quest there are two questions how do
you mutate a layer right and mutation I
believe is done in sort of different
ways here but if you look at this here
at this expression so what you have here
is the input is this signal here right
and you you always start out I believe
with the input with a layer that just
emits the number one with a layer that
just emits the number zero or
and then you have two trainable vectors
that you can include and you just start
out with these four things and then
every time you mutate you add one of
these blocks and I believe there's also
a method like a randomness of changing
the individual things or of actually
starting from scratch again it's pretty
important otherwise you just grow bigger
and bigger monsters and but the the PIO
the way you mutate is the following you
add a new block let's say I add one here
and you decide on one of the primitives
from the table right here I'm going to
simply decide on a - opera so a
subtraction operation and then once
you've done that you you choose two
children sorry two parents however you
know see it you choose two parents
because the - operation it's two parents
you choose two of the parents at random
here so I'm going to choose this thing
here to be a parent and I'm going to
choose this thing here to be a parent at
random right and then this new node will
become the new output of the layer so
you see that this was the previous
output here this multiplication node
between this and this now this is no
longer the output now this is obsolete
right this is no longer part of the
final mathematical expression here so
you see all the the gray nodes here were
actually sort of obsolete nodes but they
are still kept because in subsequent
steps you can choose them as parents and
then they become part of the expression
again you can see here this tan H node
it was just a a node that was sort of a
dead end in the expression before but
now with the new mutation it is again
included in the expression because I've
randomly selected it as a parent but
then this node here and there was reset
this node
here they are now obsolete notes because
they are no longer part of the
expression the expression in this case
would go from here to here right
including this node and it would go from
here over here
right so these nodes are now part of the
expression so this is how you mutate and
as I said you can also mutate such that
you start from scratch and so a time you
take the second part in this thing is
how do you exactly determine the winner
and what is the tournament so how do you
do that the tournament exactly is what
we've seen before when we looked at the
different layers so we said we train on
C for 10 and what we do is we train
these three architectures on C for ten
so the ResNet the mobile net and the
efficient net we train these three
architectures on C for 10 with the evil
norm layer instantiated by you know that
particular sample from the population
and then we look at their accuracies and
we do we determine what is called the
Pareto frontier of the population so I
think this is further up oh right here
okay so the the dots here the red and
the gray dots would be our sample so all
of this would be our samples and their
performance here it's on on actually on
two models but in practice we have three
just to graph it better so we put them
here we determine the Pareto frontier
now here a B and C are part of the
Pareto frontier because a perform
outperforms everything else on model 1 C
outperforms everything else on model 2
and B outperforms C on model 1 but also
out performs a on model 2 this is what's
called the Pareto frontier and we pick
one of those as the winner so they all
are kind of 1/3
winners here so this is how you do the
tournament you pick the winner like this
and then you allow the winner to mutate
the last part that is not drawn in here
actually is somewhere here ish which is
called the rejection step so the
rejection step is important because what
they want to do is they say hi we have
these mutated layers but some of the
mutations are probably going to be just
terrible
like destroying everything not trainable
layers let's just you know horrible
horrible such such that it's if the
layer is useless they don't want to they
don't want to keep they don't want to
they don't want to put them back here
into the population because that might
either deteriorate or severely slow down
this progress here so they want to stop
stop them and only the good ones only
the the ones that are somewhat fairly
okay get back to the population right
they don't always have to improve but
they have to be at minimally useful so
the rejection step they described down
here in the rejection protocols they
have two criteria for rejecting mutated
architectures first they have a quality
criterion say we discard layers that
achieve less than 20% validation
accuracy in 100 training steps on any of
the three anchor architectures right so
the reasoning behind this is if you have
a hundred training steps and you achieve
less than 20% validation accuracy you're
not going anywhere
right you're just because 10% is is
already random performance if you are
less than 20% after 100 steps your layer
is pretty useless and can be discarded
right so they say this simple mechanism
ensure
the compute resources to concentrate on
the full training process of a small
subset of promising candidates I'm sorry
yeah
so the hundred training steps of course
is not enough to train fully but you can
see after a hundred training steps
whether or not the layer even does
something so you reject those so this
makes pretty much sense right the second
criterion is what they call stability
right they say we reject layers that are
subject to numerical instability all
right and how do they find numerical
instability they define it like this so
what they do is they take the parameters
so that the layers and this is an an
architecture yeah so the model the model
these are the convolutional weights or
the the theta right and the G is the
computation graph which is the evil norm
in this case and there is a loss defined
across them of course right this is the
loss of the neural network on the
samples right so these are the these are
the convolutional layers and these are
the normalization layers now what we
want to do is we want to see how does
this loss change when we change the
convolutional layers so you have to
imagine here are the the convolutional
layers and then there are these weird
normalization layers and then again
there are the convolution layers now we
want to see how does the loss change if
we change the the weights of the
convolution by a little bit right we
just change it a little bit and see how
does the loss change this is the
gradient of the of the weights basically
this is how you train this entire thing
here is how you is how you train the
neural network right so you want to see
how large is this gradient and you kind
of want to do this in an adversarial
ways you want to find the
maximum perturbation you can achieve
right you say okay if I change this a
little bit in the in the worst direction
I possibly can how large is the is the
perturbation going to be and that that's
how they define numerical instability so
it basically means if this is very high
then the network might be doing well
right where it is but just a little bit
changing it will make it terrible right
so so they say we ascend the value on
this direction for 100 steps and layer
with the worst-case gradient norm
greater than ten to the eight or
rejected in addition so as a reasoning
seems pretty strange right this quality
criterion it it made sense but this is
the ability criterion it kind of seems I
mean reasonable but strange in here the
reason now so do tests are complementary
with each other for example we found a
layer like this is able to achieve
reasonable accuracy zhan see for ten
across all the anchor architectures so
it passes the quality criterion above
but it's gradients quickly explode on
imagenet possibly due to the absence of
normalization operations so and then you
see aha okay so what probably happened
is the following in they did their
experiment without this right just with
this quality criteria which I guess
makes sense they did this right they
trained on C for ten that's how they do
their evolutionary search then they took
their best performing things among them
is this one and they went to imagenet
and they said let's test these now on
imagenet class first like we found these
new architectures let's see and then
they got exploding radiance right and
then they went back into their original
problem formulation say okay hi what can
we build in to the evolution such that
this won't happen
and here you already see kind of the the
problem with this what you would like to
have is kind of an algorithm that is
general such as to not depend on the
architectures and so on that is used but
but you see already here that the
authors they don't direct the search
right the search is evolution but they
guide the evolution is very much guided
by what these rejection protocols are
and you you see here the author's
tailoring the rejection protocols to
specific datasets and architectures that
they use and the specific problems they
experienced when trying to to apply
their method and that I think weakens a
bit the the application of this method
because it seems that this particular
forum of protocols of this particular
form of rejection protocols is very much
tailored to this let's do these three
architectures on C 410 and then go to
image net and that tells me if I want to
do this in a very different domain that
I would have to couldn't it is not very
clear that I could just to plop whatever
they found works in and it would just
work just as out performing lis of the
others azzam as in their experiment it
tells me that there is very like
somewhat large dependence on the
specifics here yeah so but that being
said these are the rejection criteria so
they reject each step here the worst
ones and they go back into the
population and then that process repeats
and repeats and repeats and then at the
end you hopefully end up with some very
good normalization layers now I have to
see here if you compare now these are
these found normalization layers with
the classic variance so the
basic thing here is this red line this
is batch norm and really this is a
classic activation normalization combo
you put in a neural network and you see
that these methods outperform this on a
very kind of a stable basis right so so
that's pretty cool but that is as we
said on C for ten that is of the exact
thing that they search over right so
it's not really a surprise that if I you
know search a bunch of combinations and
always get the best ones I would
outperform just one of them the
interesting thing is what happens now if
we take what we found and put them into
a different architecture for a different
data set now here the architecture isn't
really different because it's kind of
the same but they do evaluate it on
image net right image net different data
set than C for 10 much larger and so
they put their their architectures which
here Evo norm into image net and they
evaluate it and you can see that it has
fairly competitive results across right
so I find that to be to be fairly cool
that the best performing ones on C 410
would also perform better than the
corresponding ones on image net but you
already see as well that it's not super
high right
so the the difference is here or I would
say it is improving but sometimes you
know it's the same sometimes it's
actually worse it doesn't it doesn't
appear to know it to me that those kind
of things are not super convincing
especially because this is the paper
that suggests these methods so they're
naturally going to present them in the
best possible way so it seems like the
massive out performance on c4
translates only marginally to imagenet
and these are the same architectures
right the resonate 50 and mobile net and
efficient that these were already the
architectures that they searched over so
my trust that this new normalization
later put into a an actual different
architecture is lesson is less still now
they do actually do some experiments on
that as well but but I just this is my
thoughts when reading this and and as
well and this I find very interesting
this column here are random search so if
you just do a random search which means
you just produce random layers then it
doesn't work at all right so you take
the best ones of the random ones you
found and it doesn't transfer at all but
interestingly if you do random search
plus rejections so the same rejection
that they do just you don't do this
tournament evolution mutation style you
simply random search and then do
rejection that gives you fairly
competitive numbers right and in some
cases even see here it does it
outperforms some of the classic methods
so so just that will give you fairly
decent results right and that is to me
that that seems to be even more a sign
of okay II this what this method is
mostly doing is just searching like mad
for something that works on these
particular architectures and of course
you can find things that work better if
you search like mad but then what do you
do with it like what does it mean it can
we generalize now they do two additional
tasks to show that it does generalize to
other architectural tasks so first of
all they do object detection and
instance segmentation
on cocoa so this is a very different
task this is a mask or CNN right and
they just put in their layer there and
you can see here that they generally
outperform the baseline I don't speak to
how much this is this out performance is
here it seems like the numbers are
fairly close together but they are
consistently better then again I don't I
don't necessarily trust these kind of
experiments too much because who knows
how much effort you can spend on making
your method better but in any case they
show that they are better which is
already something but again here the the
ar-50 indicates that we're again dealing
with like resonate 50 erina 101
architectures which are fairly similar
to the ones that we that the method was
searching over so the second thing is
they say we generalize to gain training
so they take a pic again a big and deep
and they show that their method will
outperform these other methods on the is
and f ID metrics I don't even know what
inception score and fresh let inception
distance yeah so it will outperform them
but in kind of a weird way okay here it
outperforms them consistently but then
in the inception score this batch norm +
really we see it still seems to be like
a lot higher than this Evo norm B zero
and then this thing here that was
performing worse in the image net is now
performing somewhat better it just so it
is cool result and definitely cool that
you can pop this in here i I just think
that the things that turn out here that
they are
toons two very specific architectures
two very specific tasks so I think the
big and deep the kind of architectures
will always be kind of the same it will
always be kind of ResNet ish style
neural networks and the tasks here will
always be sort of c4 imagenet style
things and therefore I believe with the
results we've seen the fact that it
outperforms so much on C 410 but then
the gains on imagenet become more
marginal I think that indicates that the
gains here most probably don't translate
the further away you go so I'm not sure
that the Evo norm that they find like
that this particular thing here will
remain the best thing across across
tasks I think they just found this to
work well in their particular setting
here and if I run the same thing with
the slightly different architectures and
slightly different tasks I will come up
with a different best thing yeah all
right so these were my comments they do
some interesting experiments where they
show that if they just do random layers
it it's not as performant which I can
believe if you just jumble these things
around it's probably not as good so you
need some kind of search criterion and
yeah that was my thoughts on this paper
I invite you to read it look at it look
at this station experiment it is a very
good evaluated paper and that bye-bye